DAN GALPIN: All right.
So first of all, I
want a show of hands.
How many people in the
audience here have any kind
of engineering background?
All right, it's quite
a lot of you here.
One of the questions
that was asked
is, should I actually show
some of the technical slides
that I have here, and
I'm going to show them.
But I'll go really fast through
them for all of you who aren't.
So when I thought about the
future of gaming at Google
and I saw all the things
that were going on here
at Play time, what I realized
is that you are already
seeing a lot of the future
in these other talks.
You're seeing the
really cool stuff
that we're doing around tooling,
all of the great improvements
we've made to Android Studio,
the addition of the NDK,
better performance tools
for game developers
and that's obviously
to continue.
You're seeing the
great stuff that we're
doing with Player
Analytics and you're
seeing all of the work
that is being built on
to give you more and
more data to help
you optimize your engagement.
So when I always
think about the future
I want to make
sure, first of all,
that we're covering
all the other stuff
that that's in the fringe
that you might not know about.
So here's about me.
I have been a
developer for years
and I'm a gamer and I
like animating slides.
So to reiterate here, we have
a billion Android devices
and I just love this picture
so I'm putting it up.
But more importantly,
most of these devices
are obviously
phones and tablets.
But the future of Android is
not just phones and tablets,
it is that device we
have sitting upstairs.
If you've had a chance to play
with it, it is Android TV.
And the idea being
here is very simple.
We create one platform and
one distribution system
and we allow it to use the
same middleware, the same store
front, pretty much all
the same technology they
you're using today
to build your games
with a little bit
of incremental work
and bring it to a
whole new ecosystem.
So part of the future
is saying, hey,
let's leverage all of
this work that you're
doing to target these billion
users that we're talking
about here on another platform.
And of course, we're building
a whole big ecosystem
around here.
And some of you may have seen
this slide before but there is
just an amazing amount of
stuff--not only do you have
TV's that have integrated--
we've got these great over
the top boxes and micro consoles
and if you haven't played with
the NVIDIA box, it is awesome.
And then we have these
integrated service boxes
that are just coming to people's
houses for a massive far
[INAUDIBLE] and
LGU plus in Korea
so it is a really cool thing, I
wanted to do a little shout out
here before I started talking
about the rest of the future.
All right so basically
we have a couple
of different groups
at Google that
are doing kind of neat
stuff for game devs.
Now how many of
you have actually
heard of Fun Propulsion
Labs, by a show of hands?
All right.
So it is a team
at Google that is
passionate about creating
cool, cross-platform game
technologies.
And basically, here's
what they do, OK?
They iterate.
They build games.
They release game components,
tools, and all that source,
and then they repeat,
see animations.
So here's how they got started.
They went and they
created this really,
really, cool library
called LiquidFun.
Now how many of you have
ever heard of LiquidFun,
by show of hands?
OK.
LiquidFun is actually
a really, really,
cool 2D particle
simulation library.
And they wanted it to be
P's-- Portable, Performant,
and Practical.
And what do I mean
when I say that?
So what I mean about portable,
it is basically everywhere.
We have ported it ourselves
to just about every platform
out there.
It is integrated into major
game SDK's like [INAUDIBLE] SDK.
It is available on
Windows and the Mac.
And it's performant
because we are
really smart about the way
we deal with these thousands
and thousands of particles.
Basically we look at the
diameter of the particles,
we put things into really
cool data structures
so that we can actually
figure out, OK.
If we're this particle,
how many other places do
we actually have
to do calculations
for these collisions-- which
is what's expensive when you
build a particle simulation.
And you might say
all right, just
based upon the
diameter you'd actually
be able to look at
these particles.
And then we do them in
order, so by the time
we get to particle seven, we're
actually only really looking
at particle nine.
So that's how we
make things fast.
And it's practical
and you know what?
And by practical, we
built it on top of Box2D,
so it just literally slots in.
If you're already
using Box2D and you
want to add really cool
particle simulations that
can flow around all of your
existing box to the objects,
you can just integrate
this library in and boom.
All of a sudden you've got
water and cool liquid effects
on top of it.
So this will give you a whole
bunch of additional options
as game developers
and designers.
So I'm going to play a video
now which is from the game
that we built. We actually
built two games around this.
And as you can see, these
particle simulations
can affect both
themselves, but also they
can affect the Box2D object.
So as our hero
moves, he actually
can be transported by these
little fountains of water.
And it's actually a part
of the whole physics
simulation of the game.
And again, all the source
code of that is all available.
So that's one thing we're doing.
That was our first game.
The second thing was this
thing called Pie Noon.
And this is when
we really started
to get into the
groove of things.
So we actually started
to put together
a whole bunch of
technologies that
are all available
as pieces that you
can integrate into your games.
And the first piece of
this that we integrate
into the game--well I'll
show you the game first,
that's probably the
important thing.
So if you haven't
seen this, this
is a cool pie flinging
simulation done sort of, 3D.
It really was a chance for us
to see how these technologies
actually work in a real game.
Of course, we have play game
services and other stuff,
let's continue on to
talking about this.
So what did we do?
So first of all, we wanted to
make sure the game was small.
Making your game small
is extremely important.
As you know, we now support
up to 100 megabyte APK's yay.
But even with that,
you still want
to make it small because
the smaller your game is,
the more downloads it has.
And WEBP is actually pretty
cool for making your game a very
small package online.
So a lot of people
see this, it says web
and they assume it's
only for the web.
But actually all these libraries
are available on mobile devices
as well.
And we actually show you how to
do it inside of all the source
code for Pie Noon.
All right.
It supports lossy and
lossless compression,
with lossless alpha channel
support in both cases.
And it'll give you
considerable size improvement
over things like
jpeg, and png files.
So again, making your
game small is important.
So how do we do this?
We started off with TARGA files,
which of course were enormous.
We then created
lossless pngs and then
we compressed those to WEBP
inside of our tool chain.
So what did this actually
look like in real terms?
So our TARGA files are
obviously enormous.
You'd never want to
ship those on mobile.
Our png files were
relatively small,
but when we got down to WEBP,
that's what we're looking at.
So you'd be shocked.
We actually did some studies.
And we found-- you'd be
amazed how many developers
are actually shipping png's
for all of their assets.
And the truth is
you might as well
go with something like this.
So here's actually
what it looks like.
You probably can't tell, based
upon this projection, actually
the difference in quality.
With these, believe
it or not, that
is the png, that is the WEBP,
this is another lossy WEBP,
and this is-- In this
one, you can just
start to see there's
a little less detail.
If you look really
closely, there's
a little fringe,
almost impossible
to tell the difference.
However, we wanted
to look perfect,
so we chose that
one there, almost
no distinguishing
differences at all.
Of course, this doesn't
get you off the hook
from using
GPU-optimized textures.
Because they are smaller,
they take less fill rate.
I'm not saying everyone should
use WEBP for everything,
but if you're using pngs
to ship textures already,
really think about
using it instead.
All right.
Let's talk a little
bit about maths.
And the next thing
we did is we needed
to create a library for math.
And actually we were doing
this independent of Pie Noon.
But Pie Noon just
gave us an opportunity
to actually take
advantage of it.
A lot of people are
like, god, we really
want a cool math
library for Android.
And this is awesome
because it can
be used for physics or geometry,
and use a SIMD compiler
intrinsics.
And that's really important
because using compiler
intrinsics, we actually
made it five times as
fast when running
on our Nexus devices
or actually when you're
running on the desktop.
It's just ludicrously fast.
So it's streamlined which
means it doesn't contain
that, the kitchen sink, yeah.
And you know so it's not useful
for doing things like protein
folding or something like that.
But it is really good for games.
And we actually used it to
calculate the arc, for example,
of our pies as they get thrown.
Parabolic pie pass, it's great.
And it all begins with p.
So we talked a little bit
about the next thing we built
was something
called FlatBuffers.
Now when we designed
Voltaire, we actually
ran into a huge problem, is that
it took forever to load levels.
And that's partially because
the system that we were building
was not optimized for games.
And I'm not even going to tell
you what we used to build it.
But trust me, it was amazing.
So we wanted to
make sure when we
did our next game
that we actually
didn't have this problem.
So we decided to look, first
of all, at protocol buffers.
We thought, those
are pretty cool.
But they're kind of
heavyweight, still, for games.
And we thought we
could do better.
So we actually developed this
technology called FlatBuffers.
And I'm excited to say this has
actually gotten a lot of play
even outside of games.
There was a great post
recently by Facebook,
where they're actually
using FlatBuffers inside
of their Android application.
And they talk about
how great it is.
So what's great about this is
it's really memory efficient.
The code base is really small.
And it's super flexible.
So a lot of you-- you don't have
to be embarrassed about this.
But a lot of people are
actually shipping JSON
to and from their applications.
They're actually
storing this in the app.
And that's really, really
bad for a lot of reasons.
One reason why it's
bad is for example,
it's really hard to
optimize, because your JSON
[? partition ?] has no idea that
those are actually [? enons ?].
And it actually has to
store them as strings.
That's really slow and
really heavy weight.
And you get things
like this number.
What does that number, and
what does that type mean?
So it's, by definition,
pretty inefficient.
But it's human readable.
And so people love it.
So what we did for
FlatBuffers is very simple.
We save a schema.
And we generate
C++ code from that.
And we actually support more
than just C++, by the way,
but that was the original
language we supported.
And then-- we then
can take an object
and turn it into a
[? bitarray ?] or vice versa,
pretty straightforward.
So the best part is no
JSON, except for the fact
that people still
like using JSON,
so you can actually build
that schema with JSON if you
want to.
If that's not confusing.
So what's great
about this is now
you can take JSON, use
it to find your schema,
generate the CPP file,
[? bitarray ?] and everyone
is happy.
So of course this doesn't take
away all of your other game
loading stuff.
But basically by comparison
to JSON, it's like this.
And if you're actually
looking at network size,
it's like 400 times faster
than actually parsing the JSON.
And if you're looking at
network stuff, it's huge.
So once again,
anything we can do
to make less network traffic,
to make the game smaller,
to make the game load faster,
we know all of these things
lead to better retention.
All right.
We also do audio.
And I'm not going to get
into great deal about this.
But mostly this deals with
sound bank management,
some very cool things which
SDL doesn't normally do,
and that's what we're
building our stuff on top of.
We of course have an
animation framework.
All this stuff we had
to build for Pie Noon.
We actually build
performance tools.
So in addition to the great
performance tools that
are built into the platform
now, the stuff the indicate team
is working on, we
have our own set here,
which actually gives these
great graphs and visualizations
to what's going on.
And we actually build some
build scripts to do it.
So again, this stuff
was all open sourced
with the Pie Noon project.
The question is, where
we go from there?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-With this new release,
we want to show you
how to take advantage
of the unique kinds
of multi-screen game
experiences you can make.
DAN GALPIN: So one
of the things we
did is when we're looking
at Android TV, we said--
-We turned our original
fast-paced pie throwing
simulation--
DAN GALPIN: I'll let them speak.
---into a strategy game.
You plan your moves in
secret on your phone,
then watch the action
happen on your TV screen.
Check out Pie Noon
on Google Play,
and give multi-screen
gameplay a try.
Then take a look at our
source code on GitHub
to see how you can use nearby
connections in your own games.
Happy gaming.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN GALPIN: So one of the
things that we actually
did to help Android TV, and
it's actually part of Play Games
but only sort of
part of Play Games
is actually called
Nearby Connections.
And Nearby Connections allows
you to very, very easily
use your phone as a controller.
It allows you to go and find
other devices that are actually
potential controllers,
that are near your TV.
And of course, we
implemented this in Pie Noon
as part of a second experience.
And that's available
now as well.
We also have a Cardboard
version of Pie Noon,
which is pretty cool.
I'm not going to
talk about that here.
But it's a pretty
cool code base,
that shows you a whole bunch
of different ways in which you
can gauge users from
a fairly simple game.
All right.
So what's the future?
So this is a preview
of what we're
going to be shooting next.
This is shot very, very low
resolution, off of my device
just a few hours ago.
And basically what
you see is we've
taken the engine we
built for Pie Noon.
We've actually added full
blown 3-D. We actually
have skeletal animation
system built into it.
And again.
We're taking-- this is
a Cardboard based game
and it's going to
be pretty cool.
I'm not going to talk too much
about what we're doing next
here, mostly because I don't
want to steal their thunder.
But as an initial preview,
that's what's coming next.
So again, we're taking
all these technologies
and we're extending them
to build cooler stuff.
Here's a whole
bunch of links where
you can find out about it.
And again, FlatBuffers
is really cool.
I really recommend
taking a look at it.
We actually have a C
sharp binding for it now.
We have Java bindings for it.
It is very, very cool.
All right.
I still haven't really talked
about much of the future.
Let me talk about one more
thing before I get to that.
How many of you know
about Firebase here?
That's nice.
I like that.
OK, so Firebase is
actually something
we acquired last year.
And why did we acquire it?
Because it was used in Nest
and because it was awesome.
It is a very, very cool
product, that allows
you to do all of these things.
And it's used by a lot
of different companies
to do real time stuff.
So what is it?
Well first of all, as its
name sounds, it's a database.
It's a NoSQL data-store that
you interface with JSON,
from a RESTful API.
And most importantly,
it's a real time database.
So as you make changes,
updates are automatically
sent to every client
that's listening.
And it's really,
really easy to use.
Like seriously,
once you actually
have set up a
Firebase instance, you
can literally just set values
into it and start using it.
So it is really awesome
for prototyping.
And I actually,
even if this isn't
the final backend you want to
use, although for me it is.
It is really, really great
just to prototype stuff.
And the other thing that
is cool that it does
is it actually has both of the
mobile SDKs actually support
synchronization.
So if you go through
a tunnel, your data
still gets sent up to Firebase.
If you want to actually
build a full offline
mode for your game, which is
really cool because it turns
out that a lot of
people get really
annoyed if your game
only works online.
So this actually allows
you to do all of that.
It has most of the hooks
to do that built into it.
Of course, it supports auth.
That's really important.
And it also has a security model
that allows you to say, OK.
I've got access to
this part of Firebase
depending on how we auth.
And it's in the cloud, as
you'd expect from something
that we're hosting.
It's production grade.
It has things like
CDN cached assets
as well that come with it, as
well as one click rollbacks,
which is cool.
So this is a multiplayer
version of "Asteroids."
And this was just running in two
different tabs on my desktop.
And you can see, even
for this, again this
is not optimized to
play "Asteroids."
I will say this firmly.
It is not doing stuff like
using potentially lossy
networking, lossy networking.
But if you want to play
with this actually,
you just go to
mmoasteroids@firebaseapp.com.
Everyone in this room can
actually play together.
It supports lots and lots of
simultaneous players blowing
themselves up.
And you can actually look at the
code and see how it was built.
This was built in an
afternoon with Firebase.
And it's pretty cool.
All right.
Actually I've got
more than this.
I'd like to say, we--
because we haven't even
got to the future yet, right?
So let's talk a little
bit about the future.
So this is really, really cool.
You guys have seen the
Cardboard stuff upstairs.
But this video here was
actually done by Volvo.
And it was done in
partnership with Google.
And it really
shows what it means
to have the VR platform that has
absolutely no limits in terms
of how easy it is
to get to people.
So Goo-- so Volvo was actually
able to give anyone a Cardboard
unit, get them into this
experience with the XC90
right away.
And you know what's great
about having an open spec
like this too is
that we literally
have people that are building
their own Cardboard units out
of whatever boxes they
happen to have around.
And of course, we're also
making a specification.
We've actually
updated our Cardboard
to Cardboard 2.0,
which is more rugged.
It has better optics,
especially if you've
seen the most recent ones.
And it also uses
the touch screen,
instead of using the magnet,
which was a brilliant solution
if you saw the original,
which has better compatibility
and reduced latency.
Of course, you know about our
partnership with Viewmaster
That's all been announced
to bring Cardboard
to a whole new audience.
So clearly VR is a big part of
the future of games at Google.
But we're doing more than
that, because you can't just
build a spec for
VR, you actually
have to help build content.
So if you-- how many of
you saw this at Google IO.
But basically we partnered
with GoPro to build this rig.
And then more importantly,
we build really, really cool
software that takes that video
that's recorded by that ring
and turns it into
true stereo VR video.
And of course, once
you're built that video,
you need a place to host it.
So of course YouTube has
built in hosting for VR video
with YouTube 360.
And finally, if
you're building apps,
you need to have a
place to find them.
And it turns out that
place is Google Play.
So we have marketing and
promotion for Cardboard
apps today.
So once again, this is
something that is really
already happening, but it's just
getting more and more exciting
as we see more and
more people jumping
onto the bandwagon of VR.
Now the next thing we're doing,
of course, is computer vision.
How many of you got to play
with the Tango demonstrations
upstairs?
OK.
I know some people might
be watching us and be like,
what's going on upstairs?
But it's really really cool.
Because this is an exploration
into the future of computer
vision.
And what's exciting to me
is that we just recently
made Project Tango development
kits available in Denmark,
Finland, France, Germany,
Ireland, Italy, Norway, Sweden,
Switzerland, and of
course, here in the UK.
So we finally have
gotten these kits out
to more of the rest of the
world, which is awesome.
It's basically a technology
that gives devices
a human scale understanding
of their surroundings.
So there are three basic
technologies that it combines.
One is it has motion tracking
and 6 degrees of freedom.
It has depth
perception, so that it
can read the depths
of its surrounding,
which is important for mapping
3-D spaces and area learning.
So this all combines
to build a view of what
it sees, detailed and accurate
internal representation
of its surroundings.
And it can be used for
things like indoor WayFinding
and augmented reality, and
also things like room capture
and measurement.
A lot of people are interested
in using this to build content.
And so what can you do with it?
Well, this is one of
those waves of innovation
that may start with games.
But it's going to
go way beyond that.
Imagine being able to
scan in your furniture,
and view it in a
possible new home.
Or home furnishing ads or
sales that are linked to stuff
like that, or being able to
quickly preview flooring,
tiling, and other
jobs while doing
things like generating estimates
and [? bill of ?] materials.
All these kinds of
things are possible even
beyond the gaming
applications of it,
which means that
obviously people
are going to want to have
this in their devices.
OK.
One final thing I
wanted to mention.
I don't know how many of you
have heard of Project Soli?
OK, well, I'll play
this video here.
Because this is
pretty cool stuff.
We actually talked
about this in Google IO.
I'm not going to
say anything more.
Other than to play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Ivan Poupyrev.
And I work for advanced
technology and projects group
at Google.
The hand is the
ultimate input device.
It's extremely precise.
It's extremely fast.
And it's very [INAUDIBLE]
for us to use it, right?
Capturing the
possibilities of human hand
was one of my passions.
How can we take this
incredible capability,
finesse of human actions,
finesse of using our hands,
but apply it to
the virtual world?
We use [? Radio ?] [? Free ?]
spectrum, which is radars,
to truck human hand.
The radars have been used
for many different things,
to track cars, big objects,
satellites and planes.
We're using them to track
micro motions, twitches
of human hands, then use that
to interact with wearables,
and [? internal ?] things,
and other computing devices.
-Our team is focused on
taking radar hardware
and turning it into
adjuster sensor.
Radar is a technology
which transmits a radio
wave towards a target, and
then the receiver of a radar
intercepts the reflected
energy from that target.
The reason why we're able to
interpret so much from this one
radar signal is because of
the full gesture recognition
pipeline that we've built. The
various stages of this pipeline
are designed to extract
specific gesture information
from this one radar signal
that we receive at a high frame
rate.
-From these strange foreign
range Doppler signals,
we're actually
interpreting human intent.
-Radar has some
unique properties
when compared to
cameras, for example.
It has very high
positional accuracy,
which means that you can
sense the tiniest motions.
-We arrived at this
idea of virtual tools
because we recognized
that there's
certain archetypes of
controls, like a volume knob
or physical slider,
volume slider.
Imagine a button between your
thumb and your index finger.
And the button is not
there, but pressing
this is a very clear action.
And there's a natural
physical haptic feedback
that occurs as you
perform that action.
The hand can both
embody that virtual tool
and it can also be acting
on that virtual tool
at the same time.
So if we can
recognize that action,
we have an interesting
direction for interacting
with technology.
-So when we started this
project, me and my team,
we looked at the project idea.
And we thought, are we
going to make it or not?
We don't know.
But we have to do it,
because unless you do it,
you don't know.
-What I think I'm most proud
of about our project, is we
have pushed the processing
power of the electronics
itself further out to do
the sensing part for us.
-The radar has a properties
which no other technology has.
It can work through materials,
can embed into objects.
It's allowed us to track really
precise motions, and what
is most exciting
about it, is that you
can shrink the entire radar
and put it in a tiny chip.
That's what makes this
approach so promising.
It's extremely reliable.
There's nothing to break.
There's no moving parts.
There's no lenses.
There's nothing.
It's a piece of
sound on your board.
-Now we're at the point where
we have the hardware where we
can sense these interactions.
And we can put them to work.
We can explore how
well they work,
and how well they
might work in products.
-Blows your mind, usually
when you see things people do.
And that's what I'm
really looking forward to.
I'm really looking
forward to releasing
to developing community.
And I really want them to be
excited and motivated to do
something cool with it, right?
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So to conclude, from the
evolution of advanced analytics
to help your business from
play games you've heard about
in previous talks, to
leveraging your Android
investment across phones,
TV, VR, and even wearables,
to technology that
helps you make better
games with native
android tooling
and open source game tech
from fun propulsion labs,
to power a Firebase
real time cloud,
and the future of computer
vision and sensor hardware.
So Google's future
and your future
have definitely got game.
And now really, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]